o ato sexual do que falar andar que
sejam muito bem vindos de mais um vídeo
e eu os trato de questões nas sete
mission me segurei porque nascemos
comichão quando o pessoal estamos aqui
para jogar à noite quatro já para a
noite em uma cadeira não o é bonito pra
casa é caótica e ninguém é que os
estúdios de games gosta não é aquela
câmera e tudo os gamers tem é esse eu
quanto meu estado eu vou e volto pra
trás basta um toque dinheiro além do
carro a hora mágica
agora além do oscar pessoal noite 4 esta
vai ser difícil para caraças bora lá a
temporada passou através do que acho que
ela vai sofrer em roupa não é sensato
escuro porque eu já esqueci como é que
este joga já muito tempo que não pega o
estilo como é que você vai querer pelo
barulho da câmara susto meu deus que
houve qualquer coisa que eu não sei
porque olhar pra mim quer tocar essa
boca não abrir a cortina não acho que
ela já está tudo aberto amanhã eu abro
muito rápido agora se ver as câmeras na
época já se não todos aqui aqui embaixo
eu acho que não tem ninguém em cima
também não tem ninguém o que quer dizer
que eu só toquei passo né não achou isso
estranho nesta quarta à noite e não
acontece nada aqui nesta sala já estava
nos é porco e vai prosseguir nesta porta
então eu tenho que achar que a porsche
ea e porto x mesmo não esquece a
importância do tempo eu acho que já se
foi embora né é preciso ficar atento
agora está à porta
usei porque vai parecer que em breve
conseguirá câmera plasmado foca 808
também que alguém esteve na direção de
alguém que me é ok não há ninguém vamos
pra trás
anda pra trás rápido fechar a cortina a
estava costurada em meu orkut nem muito
rápida é muito rápida e ganhou muita
pressão méxico é que a minha cota vai
aguentar de tanta pressão que eu tô
sentindo neste momento nem vou ver a
câmera mais são quatro da manhã jackson
assim que eu acho o sueco vai aparecer
na porta z eo buy meu porto x abc se
divertir na cortina curtinha e faz já
estava toda aberta cortina youtube julho
oi
a primeira nem na primeira parte lá
pessoa muito e 5 a jato ouviram barulho
nas portas meu deus eu não acredito que
eu vou passar a estar primeiro a
comichão eu me sentava lá mas eu saí eu
não quer saber não quer saber por que
aparecem sempre que o consumismo porque
o processo embora eu vou abrir a porta à
sua primeira já foi embora foi preciso
me cuidar e coordenem toda aberta já
anda para trás e curtindo agora tá bom e
rápido ainda mais rápida
olha você cantar aqui eu sei que é um
jargão e vai por cima e fui embora
michel eu to com esta comissão tudo
porque eu tive limpar o pó a pouco eu
acho que o espírito pop lula eles não
sair eu sei que os furinhos que apanhou
por tudo e eu acho que no fim vai usar
isso não acontece nada aqui
ai eu estava tão relaxada e favorável a
jogar esta quinta não está bom é difícil
eu sair eu já percebi ou assim que ouvir
uma vozinha eu tenho que fechar a porta
mesmo sem subir saltar lá não sou eu vou
falar muito pouquinho agora nesta noite
porque eu preciso me concentrar sério
estampa é difícil comentar e jogar ao
mesmo tempo principalmente quando você
está em 4 coisas ao mesmo tempo pra
fazer olha esta carteira tão rápida que
ela tá meu como assim
hoje aconteceu lá em cima a usa porque
os é muito bom e eu fosse o porto fosse
embora não
as pessoas embora eu fui embora
resta
eu estou apreensiva ao mesmo tempo o
kansas foi embora da festa [ __ ] é na
cdu já muito tempo não parece ninguém
está satisfeito
agora já não vou usar as câmeras ou
simplesmente vou virar a curtirem as
portas funções
ae eu cozinho cozinha a mesma sangrar
pessoal jurista não estava difícil meu
tá muito difícil eu nem sei que não te
contou a faixa muito nada em que hora
nem todo mundo dentro do gol de henry no
gol aqui no pessoal vamos ficar porque
construiu o empreendimento é preciso
mais treino nesta vergonha alguma de
como sugestão que eu consegui passar
esta noite deixem os comentários quando
consegue favorito beijo no pé fique mais
até a próxima